oh yeah what sure
now did you come from a funeral oh wait
a black but you're kind of a Korean
gangster right now a little bit yeah
watch Houston all right black shoes
black jeans black button-up shirt there
you go huh black face mask mm-hmm with
decals on it though Korean Zombie geek
okay which is also okay these are
awesome stickers I love them some would
say the best now let's talk a little bit
it's couple things you should know it
that I've never really told you and
we've known each other a long time I'm a
little bit of an amateur herpetologist
well pop whoa did you bring up my
Instagram this is I just yeah and we're
gonna talk about this little late today
Baba went deep and true into the
mountains deep drove through here and
deep and driven true now did you have
any run-ins with the law zero okay now
they probably they did put up signs for
Papa now to make you very clear that
they're not open and that's okay what I
do okay run right through sure can we
zoom in on this gyms at all possible
yeah now I'm gonna say this now now so
if you if you see my post I would
whatever you want to call it you know
sure danger new definitely not are
definitely not a grabber because I took
what I liked it but you can see there's
no rattle on here and when I stumble
upon one I like to just flicked a few
rocks at see what's gonna do just just
kind of add to stick your finger in the
cage poke the bear a little bit this
thing with suntanning
and this is downhill stuff the pop was
gonna run over now the cold-blooded
animals what's that mean that they
either body well their body will will
adjust to the fire here right yeah
everyone yeah so so so so that's what
they do they kind of get their
metabolism going I guess just on
themselves out yeah
now I'm great yeah now I'm as you know
I'm as you know I've owned three four
snakes and I'm AM amateur potala so I'm
gonna say the worst pet in the world
now listen very boring I had a Burmese
python named ice called a mice fed um
rats
my roommate in college chadman off would
watch me I would kill the rat by
throwing it against the wall I'm sorry
to everybody but is it a real hurt that
I'd heard this yeah it's a big I didn't
like doing it all hated it I feed that I
feed it to my Burmese python I had a
ball
a Burmese python had another Burmese
python now just because you own them
doesn't make you an expert this is true
I used to be I'll tell you that also you
also you also love trouser snakes love
trousers next to now but let's keep my
gayness out of this for a second okay
now we know I'm a little bit of a lion
right that's okay but then out here I'm
not lying I used to tell you the
difference between what snakes were
vivacious which means it's something
like that which was some less nice give
birth to live young some snakes give
birth eggs some yeah have eggs some
snakes are have a neurotoxin some this
snakes have a blood toxin some snakes
have a gyro and blood toxin watch out
for those you guys blah blah blah all
snout razor
trousers a snake I'm gonna go ahead and
say I'm gonna go I was gonna say
California king now here's what I think
bring up a tell for you yesterday use a
tint of red okay yesterday I was a
Terran tactical our friend Taran Butler
oh you're shooting I was I was squeezing
off some rounds I was I brought my game
up a little thanks for the invite well I
should have invited you but I thought
you didn't like doing it
what oh dude I loved shooting with him
oh I'm bringing the last year I'm
bringing you back oh yeah
offered that wasn't the snake he offered
for you and I to go and do it this
Friday we could do the podcast and go
out if we want no no I'm thinking I had
a blast I had a blast took my game to
another level um we can watch it on my I
didn't put up man scram hey but that's
definitely like king snake but the point
is connected to the fish I was peeing I
pulled out my trousers naked peeing I
look down and right in front of me is a
garter snake just sitting there harmless
and it looked like that so I'm gonna go
ahead all day it's not nothing
I didn't do you might have liked it
maybe I didn't take the Freak but I
think that's a garter snake I think it's
a Garden State - yeah and not to became
garden or snake it's a gardener garter
snake game-2 now so you're becoming a
bit of a herpetologist - well you gotta
know the animals you're gonna run into
and you got to know what your mask on it
and I have mascots around say hey I
wanted a nice [ __ ] snake I want
honey that's a rattlesnake
I wanna before we go on I want to thank
the fans and the sea of people that have
been begging for me to start the thin
boy bike club now
you'll have a bike drop merchants I have
to talk Brennan he had his lunch sure is
there money to be made I guess but the
blinding I thank you so much that did
yeah you big two men
yeah I like it yep that's it my that's a
big snake they get big
I guess car it's not bigger Carter snake
now people in the comments were like
dude pick him up grab him he's harmless
not doing why bother an animal an animal
something bother dude pros cons pros
it's just for the gram cons that thing
bites my [ __ ] neck well better my lip
or bite you and you get an infection or
you know what snake I don't want to be
picked this poppin in the thick boys
snake tattoo on his thigh yes yes let's
get it Monday but I was busy
yeah yeah I'm just begging you again
thank you for the huge interest III
can't start it I mean I will I mean I
have a beach cruiser the point is it
true this the point is I know you're
trying to get me to come down to San
Diego tomorrow and I don't know if I can
go oh really yeah Rogan asked me do this
she'll leave I have to do Robichaux do
Rogan she'll let me tell you why I don't
want pressure cuz I feel pressure to go
down we can do it another oh you don't
want to go to San Diego I mean I do but
it's a drive it's fun though it is you
and I could go a good shooting at Erin
tactical maybe bring Rogan squeeze off
some rounds do some obstacle stuff it's
all about your Potamus man Lana's by
cutting though now it's true we could
bike ride and then we can do teryn
tactical I'm thinking outside the box
you mean go to San Diego and then come
back and shoot guns do that or we or we
do some bike riding in I come out I see
it Simi Valley we do some bike riding
you see you you check me out and see how
I'm doing okay well you know I do a
backflip now right I saw the backflip
into the folding pit like a
four-year-old here's the thing about
Bryan Callen
he's 53 and Bryan Callen will do 10
backflips and no but but Brian Collins
abs sore oh they're sore and body grew
oh yeah different bodies different
muscle yeah yeah I do a backflip
you let me pull up the video burner know
you wrote hard what but you only pull
the video now if I'm doing the back yeah
in the shore they let see me does a
third one you said that dude look at
these though how up I can't watch you
let you wear your shoes in the foam pit
what dude everyone knows at the night no
but but do you know what Marcis ha ya
see a son did the same thing oh but you
know what she did a front flip but I
never thought I could do it I was just
kind of a chicken hey you didn't do it
as a backflip no it's not and that's not
even a good one bring up the good one
the world over I grabbed our knees until
you land it on the ground that you can't
do that Wow what about if I landed on
the trampoline no come on hologram the
trampoline it'd be it'd be pretty cool
on the trap but still not like the
ground well let's see where my head is
and see if I'm clearing I want to know
if I'm clearing the pad let's see if I'm
clearing the pad right so so let's see
there's the ground I don't have I can't
jump a lot there so let's see where I'm
where where my head is well I hit the
ground why this one terrified it you
wanna maybe hit the ground what have you
- well that's dangerous that scares the
[ __ ] out of me
yeah dude I hate chin we're all set hey
you can't do a backflip don't do a
backflip on the ground let your land and
you would've went face your knees would
have hit the ground in your face Goo's
you guys hey and cold hard cash to watch
you're not gonna do it can you pause it
where I'm upside down to see where my
head is that's what I want it now yes
see where the legs are the landing
yeah right no you see that that's the
ground that's that would be the ground
baba whoa right there would you see that
well that's a problem right in the
[ __ ] ground
there David your neck ah that scares me
I need you quit saying you can do a back
foot I didn't wanna have to do this you
have to do this just chin just slow down
you don't break your [ __ ] neck dammit
dude that just made me nervous
and you sent seven those videos to all
of them it's not on the back foot leave
that
you know you went headfirst into the
cement did I did I didn't I didn't know
your daughter's close to clearing it
there the whole thing's a bad idea for
53 year old had the whole Jeff Foley
said a tough Brian there is zero reason
for a 53 year old to do a backflip you
have zero reason for it and you're right
unless you want to be awesome Jeff
that's right
let show me the awesome 53 year old yeah
she Sydney who's the champ Sydney Olson
who yet world champion freerunner and
women's division said that she taught a
50 and 80 year old man do a backflip her
friend's father really I was like I
don't believe it and I'm gonna do it I
don't believe her I wonder though I
think she was probably meant like into
the foam pit and you know I said I said
if you're hot you like I get a
congratulations and then he goes Jenna
foam it's in the phone though yeah I was
like on the phone dude we that was a
better one I think oh yeah can you do a
back flip or a front flip cap nope when
you're a kid you can I feel you because
no only cartwheels you can cartwheels
are will challenge and like to do a good
cart where with your legs are straight
and don't fold like a scorpion yeah I
was always afraid that's really what it
is yeah you'll be pretty I can't commit
to a list well the way you work you work
from there and you put up now you put a
pad there not a foam pit you know it's
all it's a process keep going every day
but then boy backflip club guys it's
starting and we're meaning to I'll fight
like how fearless was Tiger with Tiger I
know he's amazing he's amazing that kid
well he's too fearless he scares me
yes um agree he's so rough he's amazing
I was trying to describe to him today
because since it's hot out where we live
you know they even we bought the house
so I came in just to beat you know you
have little ones make sure you watch out
for snakes when he goes in the backyard
I keep them all the all of it all the
videos I post I send to his mom first so
she can show Tiger why you're home I
show up I know dude look the if you hear
a rattle what do we do
I've told him so many times run just
don't mess it run the OPP's away right
in the house yeah I think it's gonna pop
I'm fast
yep no I know it fast he says he's the
best boy in the world like I know you're
fast around snakes much faster I don't
know like dude I'm telling you man so
I'll see a rattlesnake
if you're on that's why I go you run it
makes me angry and I start going well I
go what do you do he's hit my hand he's
amazing Maya and my buddies I want my
the most stressful vacation I've ever
had was I went to Costa Rica my buddy
Dan and his two boys and in my children
now Costa Rica is home to the fair to
Lance and also [ __ ] and [ __ ] Brandon
cuz we had a Hornet we've been there to
get really that's a party that we that's
right and there are we went into a bar
thinking it was a bar and I'm not joking
it was a piranha barn I couldn't believe
I went I go there's been I go look at
these what's all these girls doing and
Brennan goes I don't know and then I
walk in and I'm like why am I being
treated like I'm Elvis Presley I'm not
that good-looking
and then we were like oh these are
hookers it was a sea of hookers but
unbelievable yeah I mean I was that
wasn't stri was I was appalled I was - I
was appalled I was I didn't take well
bring this up there you go that's the
kind of [ __ ] you have to deal with in
Costa Rica I don't approve I don't
approve I think it's an outrage if
you're into girls from Colombia and
Panama and that part of the world who
are crazy curvy and just $25 go a long
way some would say the longest out this
so I'm would say the longest Brendan
I don't know first hand I've heard I've
heard
there you go hundred dollars you're
living like Elon Musk out there they
have a hundred bucks you live in like a
lon um they're trying to suck that test
Tesla to you well there's there's there
are some believe tried some snakes or
are plenty oh dude Chow's of snakes are
just but I'm there I'm as you would
appreciate us because his kids are at
the time he's got a four-year-old he's
got a six-year-old now these kids were
amateur insect ologist and snake ologist
is of course problem was we got
poisonous frogs
we got fair to land
we got Boomslang so shriek at us oh we
got some of the scariest [ __ ] snakes
around uncle ceddy right we got weird
Lance's with you now we got Hornets
aplenty we got fire ants we got killer
Hornets up there dude
these kids were groping at anything they
could find the bushes and and the poison
dart frog was the dad thing well dad was
[ __ ] worried too on top of the fact
they found a 20-foot crocodile on the
goddamn [ __ ] beach because the river
head was just oh a quote unquote
200 meters down the way he founded the
kids it was on the beach in the morning
and they told so I go I got my kids in
this water that I can get the [ __ ] out
of here I was so stressed I finally
grabs kids I go look at me oh and then
they have the they have the eyelash
Viper or whatever it's called us then
the hanging of the trees but rather than
want more day yeah they bite you in the
face and I saw one we saw one and I'm
like dude this this whole situation is
very dangerous hey hey I swear yellow my
last fight right we saw I don't know cuz
I last we saw they're better than water
that thing is [ __ ] terrified it's
also adorable
now what we did we did and you know
while they look at how to train with
maggot the guy had to I went out to me
that one doesn't yeah but the guy had to
point it out too because I didn't see it
until I got right up on it because
that's about my slash dude i my eyes are
so trained cuz when you're mountain
biking especially on the narrow trail
which it's a single path yeah and
there's just you know twigs and
everything my eyes just glued to the
ground my headphones are out and I'm
just going I'm just waiting for any sort
of movement or think and whenever if I'm
on the dirt trail it's really hot out I
know I know their ways I don't like to
come Sun Tan so if I see a like a stick
that looks like this one I always go
around of course and I come back and if
it's a snake I get off
film it free hose never when we were on
motorcycles and I got on the back here
is like a [ __ ] we're all covered in
mud all covered in mind I was so funny
that was a great I was a great time that
20 was that 20 years ago I got a little
story for us Kruger National Park we
talked about then
Kruger National Park yeah now as a as a
as a as a team player which is what I am
I go well if you're talking about it
Brandon and I would be not only happy to
go take a tour of Kruger National Park I
don't know what the [ __ ] it what we're
talking about oh I'm sorry
so so in South Africa some by National
Park in South Africa Kruger National
Park oh we've been offered eight a
special tour you and I um and we can go
in Africa yeah and then we can do
stand-up and Cape Town other including
I've talked to just about that tickets
we're good dude oh wow hey I'm working
it out right now alright look you doing
deals therefore I do deals now I got a
lot of stuff long hey man are the money
under the table are you stealing from me
guys that's right they're like the bra
yeah no we give you a hundred grand you
think anything Brian told you just get
the petal on it you're gonna get a
stipend you're gonna get a stipend I'm
doing cool like just became free doing
you know cool white shirts you kept my
shirt in a free round that's all but
that would be pretty cool wouldn't it we
could maybe we bring chin and cat and do
a whole fighter than the kid can we
shoot those things I'm serious dry
mountain bike out there it's probably
pretty far as the problem mountain
pretty flat here's a problem outlying
dose that things moving kind of looks
like a gazelle yeah he's really tan yeah
I'm gonna rip his fat head out we can
bring it up on YouTube the antelopes
sometimes decide this guy is a rival and
I'm going to hit him in the face a
mountain bike a bike in Napa now buy a
[ __ ] I'm today I got to be honest out
of all the chapters Africa's pretty thin
it's not your chapters we haven't had
many African no it's Graham videos no we
have Arizona reached out three name went
Arizona strong sent me a pic of a ton of
the I guess there's no chapter got
together to guide man
oh oh well dude I heard that's a cooter
that's a guy [ __ ] up well I would
imagine probably but the planes are
pretty flat out there I don't feel like
you'd be mentally I just think there
there are there are [ __ ] lions nose
and those I were at a Jayhawk and you
got some snakes out there ah we got some
hahaha everything rattles hey what's the
most dig in Africa Cobras right that
they have Cobras they have they have
[ __ ] cape cobras well in fact Brennan
they don't have the King do they they
have the the king cobra I believe in
this is in India but it's also in Africa
you know I did it's also I know I did my
son to scare him from touch and snakes
I showed him videos of a king cobra
eating a deer you can't give a flying we
got we got the black mama and we got the
green mama
now you're dead well we got the
Boomslang omega-3 as bushmasters Costa
Rica is the Bushmaster boom slangs you
don't want to [ __ ] around with them now
we got cobras we got the Cape Cobra and
we also have the King Kong I believe we
got the forest cover Egyptian cobra get
the leopard snake African rock python
that's a problem do we have I want to
know if we have some beak City where
Oprah yes now to go black my Cobra
sitting Cobra lot of Cobras out there
ass not fun no ass mambas and bush
vipers pushing that word red spinner
sobre Jesus dude we got lots of stuff
for bull snakes pythons
yeah we're not worried about pythons not
worried about multi Suns not worried
about that either got a lot of lot of
snakes in Africa got everything girl
everybody in Africa okay her body in
Africa you know what they got everything
we got got earth got fur Gadar got
Berg's a dirt got gaboon we know we got
the Goblin huh
oh he power I don't know if I'm gonna
mount like a horned adder bring that up
bring up the Horned adder I want no part
of the old horn Dadar dude oh you know
what I saw today
I'll see nothing like this goddamn Jesus
Christ thanks I don't want that Satan's
eels do
samesies things eels a thought I call I
like it
tears are dirt serpent earth sir dude I
thought it looked like a horned a horned
lizard you use like shaped like a dying
cow its called a horny toad no he wasn't
a toad it was a lizard but it's called a
warning to clean up a horny toad horny
toad I believe it's called a horny toad
lizard lizard yep that's what I said
today
yeah that's exactly what I saw today
yeah pretty cool chunky good-sized
lizard school or lock yeah yeah little
smaller than that but I know you mean oh
no no I saw one but you know well no
with the tail I'll tell ya we bring back
bring back in now that's all that's all
curable just like that they're adorable
I like this they don't move they like
dude run me over and my [ __ ] misery
bro yeah take your [ __ ] stump jump
and run riding my top African head I
might I might have to accompany you we
might have to go on a little bike ride
on the on the bike you'll be able to
hang dude those e-bikes I mean yeah I'm
not a biker so I think that ebike you
the bike I'm telling me by I'm sure I'm
sure
like I would [ __ ] yeah dude that look
like armadillos I would truly love to do
that I don't do it I'll meet you love I
love it I get addicted and I got
something else there you won't get I got
something else to say what this homeless
situation in Venice is out of control
you wanna do sell on fire public I might
want to move out your way you get my way
I said it
look man you and I on outdoors can bike
I start lifting taking get on charity I
get thick let's true ok now are you by
club I own part of the company you're
like here you go here shares what I
don't think so I'm just kidding I want
to thank everybody for the incredible
interest in the thin goodbye Club yeah
then there's a lot of a lot of homeless
dude dude there's so much and you know
what they're gonna do is spend 200
million dollars on 140 apartments
that'll take care of $140
that's a small sample day thanks
utilities that's the population around
[ __ ] ground where guess what bro how
there's money in in dealing with
homelessness and it's the right so now
there's monies you can make money you
get money from the state to build
homeless shelters in primo real estate
okay I'll venison and they don't come
and go and get drunk
hi everyone and P and then go all of us
are on lockdown you got all those people
so we can't and the cops can't enforce
the law you know they can't really say
[ __ ] watch the cops what they have to
deal with with Alma yeah daily give this
[ __ ] that take it for riding his bike
yeah and we we have because we have
decriminalized loitering and all that
stuff
and you've got it's a high it's an
addiction and mental health proud papa
who knows the answer to solving homeless
but didn't Venice there are people that
no one else yeah there is there is real
estate there is places where you can
build shelters but they don't want to go
to shelters why because they have to be
clean and if you got a suite you can
still get loaded you used to be you were
like you're not allowed to be on you
know ten of you are not allowed to be on
the street like this with all your trash
it's called [ __ ] loitering
that's all so how do you like ground
works isn't like hey get the [ __ ] out
here because you can't and you know
behind ground works is one of the best
mechanic shops for all like exotic cars
really the best small like hole in the
wall show those hard-working people have
to deal with this [ __ ] and they're not
allowed to do anything cuz the cop and
they're not nice of the are that the
cops are not allowed to move them you
have to understand if you have a shelter
there you can put all your [ __ ] up where
you can smell it where there's all kinds
of stuff come just take a look at Venice
it's [ __ ] Skid Row and the cops are
not allowed to message that I stopped
running my bike is that when I lived up
there used to write in the morning on
the path there but in the morning is
when they don't move so they're on the
path there it's like it looks like the
walking dead and if you do you ride
before 7:00 it's the walking dead and if
you steal 9:00 something that cost 998
dollars and you do it 10 times it's
still a misdemeanor you know it's not a
felony oh and so you get right back out
you don't get arrested for it the cops
can't enforce the law let cops enforce
the law the way we always have
but liberal [ __ ] city councils who
just let people it's a it's a it's a
multi-pronged problem but dude how about
your your boy your gay brother
newsome's open him back up I'm Friday
phase 2 I'm Batman
yeah psycho my dad yesterday bad idea
Brendon bad idea because we don't we
just you know we'll talk about Tiger
catch up a little bit why he thinks we
getting a Corona and it's World War so
he thinks he should be shut down its
World War 3 and then I he's like he owns
a small company he's the cooler you
start shouting each other sakru you two
have a small business you don't think I
want to open up and I mean I'm in the
section that should be most scared I'm
64 years old I'm like yeah but you have
no underlying health issues diabetes ago
dad you're healthy as [ __ ] and also I
don't I go and then I tried like the
escalating situation I know but Denver
is actually one the best cities you guys
opened up under the radar you didn't
announce like all you guys opened up and
you're a democratic state which is rare
because you know for so many reasons
with the Trump economy ago which is rare
pretty cool it was pretty cool we're not
fine we're actually number 14 and the
most deaths but he's but I don't
understand see okay so so this what
happened so I go dad debt so we're
shattering each other your dad when I
can do this you you say one thing I say
one thing I said let's just I'm gonna
take tighter the gym with this gym I'm
like and when we come back let's just
redo this he was okay and they start
sending me articles I'm like all right
so I text jag you send me the articles
then you know Jay
so then Jay starts sending me and my dad
the articles good and then and what'd
your dad say now what is he what is his
position do people want to keep this
lockdown going for a year until what
what I said I said daddy everybody
unfortunately you know people are gonna
fight and people die every year in a
minute yes every single year I'm the flu
and a lot of other things you see how
heart disease went down yeah yeah you
see how they they were they suddenly in
the Carroll County Mart disease
hospitals they get I think $26,000
reactor so it's called this corruption
in a number of course where that just
comes with anything but yeah you know
it's just yeah you know it's I don't
know well no III my thing is that
obviously there are vulnerable people so
there's a truck there should be a
targeted quarantine I'm so confused as
to how people think we can continue to
do this and want to continue to do this
did you know I'm saying like that that I
like a doctor a bad actor who's for the
Indian guy who got jacked it took
steroids yeah I'm gay I'm Paul I'm and
give I'm with you such a person he's you
know I don't know if he's trying to get
it you know a role with Hollywood
whatever you trying to do there the only
issue is the reason why she's so
sensitive his wife has a underlying
health care okay and she's very upset
I understand it so I think that's why I
thought that that's what it's like dude
I understand but he's like we need to be
more shut down let's shut down in 2022
it's like dude shut the [ __ ] up and film
a Marvel movie well also also you can't
write also we can't afford to and here's
the other thing that so so I was talking
to some friend of mine and we both know
is a big producer and does a lot of
movies and stuff and he said hey dude
you're missing it
we're talking about insurance now
getting insured for a film getting
insured for a big theater show getting
is short for anything is so difficult
there are so many issues now when you're
trying to shoot a movie or just even TV
getting the insurance and because if
somebody leaves set goes back and brings
it back and people get sick you're
directly get sick for three three weeks
you shut down production nobody wants to
do that so it's it's the ramification
vacations are so [ __ ] heavy
well Germany is starting their a soccer
league which is a good thing yeah
South Korea started their baseball
league which is a good thing you'll see
us seize this Saturday but my dad did
make me laugh so I'm give him all these
packages hey stop stop say goes
quit crying we're opening up hey guys
yeah I know he's like so what he talked
about was he can it's just taking
forever egos they're gonna get there I
was like all right man I'll take you
later yeah he's right I I when I
panicked five and panicked for a long
time not me I not me Manny you know a
force break you would have never taken
this long break it's your you're gonna
come out the gates like a madman yeah
everybody is high if you're smart about
things I've written a lot of new [ __ ]
it's come up with a lot of if your
comment gonna have a few new bits what
the [ __ ] you mean oh the past three
months I mean like that for three months
I've started a new business yeah I've
lost the [ __ ] eight pounds yeah I've
become obsessed with mountain biking
yeah you know I'm not special I'm not
even in the biking keep going that's
what the fans are saying I don't give a
[ __ ] I get it's been a good thing man
you know you you make chicken [ __ ] and
chicken soup now we are the ones you
know who are fortunate where we don't
have
underlying health conditions when on the
susceptible shows the workforce bubble
shows most of the economy true right
well we say most it'd be ninety eight
point eight percent right there you go
and and those the real stats for most
people show asymptomatic this is I just
I've looked at it but I I read I read
this article out of this this scientists
in England and they hit bad out there
and he said the scariest thing is is how
they can take away our rights and our
freedom well we're also willing to
that's what he was where I have a few
ideas he was doing this shutdown where
we've had pandemics before we've had
things worse than this happen this we
didn't shut down he goes would have not
been smart to give us a guideline tell
us the risk and then leave it up to our
choice I that's what I think that's how
I feel I do think there are certain
animal emergent isn't that the most
American thing you can do well I did
what's fascinating when they carried you
for riding my bike and I was a Rage
Against the Machine aah oh my god yeah I
was like oh I'm gonna start a goddamn
revolt have you guys have you guys
actually seen the numbers that came out
Italy how many people died because they
said 25,000 not true it's a lie it's a
[ __ ] lie
take a look at the actual numbers from
their health their health ministry take
a look at the actual numbers it's not
all close calling the microchip money
that might you know my dad so sensitive
but also this one of the smartest people
I know and he goes so we kindly we
finally kind of cool off things in his
yeah I'm just dying to see Tiger I just
I told Debra I'm gonna grow my hair up
that I see Tigers it's getting down you
know past my ears like oh that's sick
that for at your age to be able to grow
here like hey just get here yeah and he
goes yeah I gas is just something I'm
gonna do Thai see Tiger that's my thing
oh yeah all right well you you should be
able to fly pretty soon here you know if
you want to wear a mask and we're I'm
asking you come to LA I have a open spot
for you get you on a bike yes yeah we're
not flying anywhere well we were gonna
drive there I started laughing at the
fact he was gonna drive and that didn't
go over well didn't go over well you
guys have a bit of a competition yeah
you you bang heads you're bang heads
yeah
stuff to bang head men are very
competitive and I would have to say I'm
not with my friends or with other dudes
it's not no you say that time can pay up
but mine you are my family likes to
argue yeah Jay loves a good argument my
dad loves a good argument yes he does
loves it absolutely loves it but I feel
like my mom but I'll I so I can argue in
the meat and then if you give me a stab
or something then I'm like all right
yeah I don't I'm the most open-minded
person if we have people you know you
don't stick to your ground you don't you
flip-flop like if I'm doing a show with
Rogan Rogan says something and it makes
sense I go oh [ __ ] yeah I'll be about my
point the harder if that point made more
sense you have to be attached in one of
the biggest things is not to be attached
to your position or your ideas this is
an idea I have based on the data I've
seen if you have new data it's exactly
like corona I you know I'm not I'm not
[ __ ] I'm not ideologically married to
you know the idea that the Coronas not
dangerous it's dangerous for some people
and I have a guy and I care about that
when people go it's fake that's weird
but but i but i but i'm but i'm going by
data that i have looked at and tried to
look at closely if you have new data
that tells me otherwise please was
pretty smart right I would say he
appreciates that all his crazy and
thinks where he's like hashtag free
America [ __ ] this I'm so much I'm
leaving America all that stuff yeah
excuse can read stats he's like open the
[ __ ] up dude I agree and I agree with
his buddy like test so what do you think
about Elon Musk one thing we can all I
don't care what your opinion of them is
he's smart as [ __ ] hey smart yes and
he's also he's done something right he's
done a lot of things right yeah I mean
he he looks at stats to see people who
are [ __ ] who are just walking around
and and wearing masks and just doing
what they're told without it feels like
questioning questioning and looking
enough that's most people though and you
know most people then I think they look
at the news they would get CNN more
cases in LA the mullet well cuz we're
testing you know it's not it's not that
the think spreading like wildfire
it's we're testing your so if forces
give me more cases but you all you
should give a flying [ __ ] about
mortality if if
the mortality is going through the roof
then we get prompt yeah but it's not
yeah you know me desperate endeavor
yesterday you know how many how many how
many think 0 0 20 21 or something how
many people in prisons get it and there
are asymptomatic yeah but all the level
in prison how about the all the old
people 700 people on a cruise and they
were they were crammed and that should
have been our 7-day that should be learn
who had underlying health yes and old
yes
and all and that's what I feel like
there was this there was this rush to
shut things down and you got a guy like
Falchi saying you will pay it I mean I
just thought it was he responsible and I
still do I and I think I just feel like
in America you know I don't know how it
works you know they should have met here
it's what we know people over this age
you gotta be [ __ ] you got a standing
stay inside for people with under arrest
of you don't go around those old people
continue to work continue the economy
and do this I just feel like that was
probably a smart way to go I do too and
I think history over history will bear
you out yeah I think it's dude how about
yesterday Anna's birthday and I forgot
we hired a mariachi band
so I'm brush my teeth American I cried
7:00 a.m. but they didn't so I mean the
loud is horns you but leave this in your
house
she was so happy she said she's looking
your wife your girl is looking so
worried about working out I don't mind
saying it I know I am you plugged me
looking at her you caught me looking at
you looking at her ass and a knock did
you not though well she's [ __ ]
standing there and I'm looking and
Brennan goes looking at my girl's ass
huh he's poking at your ass I was like
hey man give me a minute
Crawley can't stop seeing Goodell not
yet see you tomorrow
and then also her birthday you know they
were great too the singers are freaking
great they were good and then Mother's
Day Sunday and I go what do you want for
Mother's Day shoes I want that panda
generally did they kick him twice I
pulled the krona card I'm like I'm not
risking the kids she goes oh now you're
gonna pull the Kronecker I don't feel
like any mariachi band
one is one time is enough for your life
hey I'm a bee you know what I felt like
or you remember the Ben Stiller movie if
Heartbreak Kid where he's like trying to
have a conversation all he goes did he's
like it don't stop stop that's how I
feel I I is they kept playing I had to
get that you know I had to go to work
nothing nothing embarrasses me more then
when I'm eating somewhere like or
anywhere and they come up and they start
playing oh and then you have to eat you
have to watch them and you're like so
you're gonna just play your instrument
worse you're terrible music that I've
heard a thousand times here in my face
the violin that's the other thing I came
over the country I was in it might have
been Greece and I'm there and the guy
comes up with a violin and begins to
play he's alone so now all of us have to
be like never have to be like and they
go quest I'm like I have no [ __ ]
regrets to father left Rafi got my
father can I see you here let Ravi out
that would have thunk it isn't like hey
did I know you're into classical music
[ __ ] off yeah those boys played long and
hard uh her all her frame - they're
always in there they all look exactly
the same
the accordion who the [ __ ] plays the
accordion in a restaurant and Tiger did
not like it all bosses start crying
yeah too much for you yeah that's right
he didn't five-month-old the
five-month-old it's like tiger well they
don't want to be polite their lever
they're just doing what everybody's
thinking get out of here
well yeah get out your dinner jammies
we're trying to watch the new Rick and
more dog you know with that horn and
those [ __ ] violins [ __ ] all of it and
it's always the same song man Anna man
Anna ha ha have you seen the Mariachi
band play post Malone no oh yeah cuz his
he's friends with that Chinese that
Asian rapper uh rich Brian ok rich Brian
hired a mariachi band for post Malone's
birthday a couple years back and played
congratulations that's pretty cool oh
yeah he's doing think for Mother's Day
oh this is it and he's playing with him
I mean some of them are awesome
musicians now look at my face and I'd
like you to look at my package but I
actually own a manscape and used it
today on my mustache now now I know it's
usually used for another reason and I
use it there too but I clean it alright
now I come Eisenhart I carved Free
American in my pubes and that's your
right as an American and manscaped is
therefore you can only do whatever it is
you want to your pubes or you and you
don't have to worry about nicking your
nuts anymore you don't have to do that's
the Nance Gant is here to make sure your
balls are smooth and also smelling nice
for spring clean the lawnmower 3.0 it's
waterproof it's cordless it's got a ton
of other things it'll give you a whole
man's how about it's waterproof mine has
a frickin light on it so I can see my
dick got a ceramic blade to prevent
manscaping accidents oh my god and guess
what inside the perfect package also
find manscaped crop preserves an anti
chafing baldie order and moisturizer say
wha
Reviver keep your balls smelling fresh
oh my god for limited time subscribers
get two free gifts the shed travel bag
$39 value and the patent in
high-performance anti chafing Minsk a
boxer briefs ever had though this is the
perfect package for the summer man if
you're on that perfect package you gotta
have your [ __ ] trimmed up man your
prints are not free shipping with the
code fighter 20 at manscape Tom do
yourself a favor and always use the
right tools for the job
you 20% free shipping with the code
fighter 20 at manscape comm that's 20%
off and free shipping at manscaped comm
use code fight or twenty it's spring
cleaning baby and your balls will thank
you yeah Miami I think they're in a
music festival like Miami is that post a
long time another night yeah it's a
couple years ago it's a big fella isn't
now post was part of the thick boys bike
club now hey is he slimmed down since
then though he looks good now I wonder
if he likes up to playing his song he's
like yeah I know this one dude this
mariachi band is having a hard time
right now one that one play in the dry
guitar is so ashamed yes the places it's
all his entourage jumped in all charges
are so clean aren't they mm-hmm I think
so too what do you guys do who is it
Neil Brenner says there you never want
to be a movie stars best friend here's
exactly
there's nobody dumber than a movie stars
best friend they're always super dumb is
so each's we're not even going into his
father you've read it without even get
in yeah just like oh yeah they all take
always I met and they're always trying
to scheme like some deal or something I
was at I met one of a very famous movie
stars best friend introduced me as his
best friend
and he was sitting there smoking weed
off the business man nothing to do he
was wearing shitty I was like hugging
like his best friend is he's on the
payroll
yeah I know a couple of I know a couple
of very famous movie stars best friends
and it's not a good look they're just
the guys ain't no Brazos [ __ ] man like
you just hanging on there hanging around
that's why that moved that show
Entourage I was
you guys just hang around huh just
hanging around
oh yeah I want my boys round but no
nobody that's my friends gonna want
looking back did I get [ __ ] to do that
what hanging you're greener water out
there you tell a bunch of ingrates after
a while they're gonna be like I don't
like this [ __ ] I got a boss [ __ ] off
there's also something weird about you
be wanting an entourage I don't want to
punch you just like a lot of my best
friends around and [ __ ] what I always
say to my features for example like or
an MC is your your job is to get the
[ __ ] out of here my job is to expose you
your job is to get so good do you become
a headline yes right so that's my now
your job isn't to be with me you don't
the features and I'm in carry my bag or
do anything for me your job is to make
my show better
yeah but also care a bit yeah yeah yes
kidding yeah how about some comics do
that they make their features and emcees
carry this well if you do that you're an
[ __ ] I know and if I'm friends even
though I'm out we know Gator then if you
do that you don't tell me who it is
because if you tell me who it is well
I'm not I'm gonna say something you
definitely I'm a common ask yeah Derek
was like he was like jerk Poston you
know he's my future he'd go dude you're
so nice to us you treat us like we're
you know we're peers
yeah he's used to having to get bags and
I didn't get dinner for him like what oh
what's him to [ __ ] off is it cuz then he
won't bring around the RO is it just
just cover your face Missy oh really
mm-hmm
I was gonna have on the podcast he's not
on the podcast come on he'd be good yeah
yeah all right then I'm gonna call him
out yeah see if you gotta bring it up so
he does the [ __ ] dummy I'm gonna calm
a dummy and I'm gonna have to and I
might you know what I mean I might
surf-and-turf um cuz I can't I might do
it because I might surf and turf for me
it's the old school away it's not an old
school way it's a losers way
yeah you're being an [ __ ] agree
whenever I hear [ __ ] like that you've
told me things about people and you know
what happens to me
maybe you tell me about certain people I
go you do this I call it the old clique
it's a clique in my head
like a little tall grass and I'm like oh
I'm always this with you bro
I'm always got my eye on you and you'll
never the lights can never go out I'm
never digital I told right about
something these these guys did and they
saw Brian like what's up man ranch goes
like this goes away that's what I do you
know that once I got the old tall grass
out dude shits open it up cuz I had to
talk to Justin yesterday he goes what do
you think of Huntsville in June Oh
Huntsville Alabama is like we carry
assault rifle in the open we have
Confederate flags now funny of a [ __ ]
about coral no goddamn gala Alabama
Huntsville was where I went
ie people aren't educated I did this
joke about like III remember that I used
to joke about town well I mean it's I
like my clean engine design sucks trying
to get helium I strokes I try it I
stress to stick to a helium isotropy
trying to get proton stick see
heliumites drummers like point either do
this thing I go hey guys I've got that
joke that kills the Rockets yeah I go
you're not you're not educated right
joking around I thought there were a
rocket scientist and this very red
redneck neck reckon that red redneck
[ __ ] she was I swear to God 63 years old
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
don't call me uneducated you piece of
[ __ ] I went whoa did I strike a nerve I
had to stop everything and go in and my
ladder oh yeah dude it was crazy and
explained yeah apparently huntsville has
the most rocket scientists like a per
square mile that's where I think NASA
through NASA um yeah so uh you know I
think with Huntsville you will see
people in the Walmart with an ak-47 with
an assault rifle slung over their
shoulder you think I'm kidding it's so
we yeah that's what they do
dude yeah you can just walk around with
a gun
hmm at least that's what I saw with my
own eyes
there yeah yeah that's what I saw
I do just walking around with an assault
rifle slung over his shoulder so yeah
there you go
did they have a shooter out there no
cell Beliveau but you can carry a gun on
the outside of your body cuz it's a
Second Amendment and that's the way it
is
tell you what though everybody has it
gonna feel a little safe he'll be
choosers
thank you ready to pop off a little
buddy yeah there is what they do me look
at that target yeah it's gonna be for
Mother's Day okay nope my mom's back in
the bay so can't really do anything
besides FaceTime you should drive up
there it's a long drive is your day like
a five cent I owe a little bit though
yeah but if it's on Sunday I gotta be
back here for working on Monday but you
could leave Friday true true
how bad you wanna see your mom in jail I
wish I could see my parents but oh but
they're older yeah
tsubame are you doing anything I'll send
my mama flowers in Denver and then all I
was thinking about killing somebody stay
for Joe Mira mariachi band some [ __ ] I
got it from others day what do you do
Brian I'm going to like you can send her
a file of my Corona just sent a fax in
Corona positive facts yeah I'm gonna
what am I gonna do I'm going to send her
flowers what else can you do I don't
know what to do but you know she's my
mom I know but she said why though just
flowers get the job done gets the job
done so she's doing well I'm gonna go
see him apart turns 80 May 25th so
daddy's gonna go to you know I'm I'm I'm
ghosting my dad
you're the fly I'm gonna [ __ ] yeah I'm
gonna fly do I have to wear a mask yes
the whole time yes I have trouble
wearing a mask I don't
you know your heart well Matt's can I
use that if that I've got bandana use a
bandana
but none would be good I'd wear a
bandana Madonna
it looks cool too I'm gonna break you in
Rob everybody I like that
me too all right you're like you mean
gangling or the food that you under
there mr. Callen um you'll see Saturday
I'm excited about that are we gonna wash
that together I don't think so why not
me you grill Oh Jeff Foley listen hold
on
but go we'll go to Frank you know I
don't like to watch my through this no
but we're not gonna say anything it's
Tony Ferguson just engag I can't I can't
believe God's the greatest art of all I
can't believe Dominick Cruz is fighting
say who - I had no idea I can't [ __ ]
believe that that's gonna be [ __ ]
Francis and Donald versus roses stroke
is unbelievable
Stephens kit is unbelievable Greg Hardy
Castro's fun Cerrone patio is on the
prelim why is that on Freeman well look
at the rest of the main card where would
you put your impetus in other words they
don't they don't they're both long in
the tooth so they date so Jeremy
Stephens Trump's Donald Cerrone and
Calvin kadar does cuz he's impressed
he's awesome belt yeah he's [ __ ] very
impressive Peniston cowboy
they're both longing to hmm talent
caterer wins that one he's up there dude
you talk about real contenders up there
Hardy yeah that's the Castro that's it
but also yeah remember they always put a
big two big names on the main event of
the prelims
so you get excited and bright it's a
[ __ ] great than Roger that I'll hold
that for a big pay-per-view on the
prelims when I fought Lavar Johnson
uh-huh I'm very happy with that prelim
card you will yes Roni Pettis ver doom
Olynyk has Cerrone Pettis they haven't
fought before happen they have today 13
Pettis beat him in Broomfield Colorado
body shot close right
Carlos Carlos noxus for as far as with
Michelle Waterson you're at Hall Jacare
and then before even all that
Vicente Luque verse Nico price should be
that could be other I wish they were on
the main card they should open up the
main coach Charles Rosa hasn't fought
for a long time I feel bright mitral
that's the fun one sound say I'm up
Alvie all these are great great fights
yeah man can't wait Rodin's doing it
Brogan John annek of DC the a-teams
going out there well I'll watch it
together
not happening you're gonna speak on the
card
Wow it's too big in Ricardo get a focus
what do you mean you gotta focus I can't
have you guys you know you know hugging
Iggy you're Frank the body shop no get
your hands up Oh God
we trained enough divorce I trained I
can't dude I might as well I trained
with Brian filaria who goes you have
good fundamentals and I want I want you
guys handle oh yeah there you go hate so
the thing is is I'd rather watch other
Buffalo Wild Wings than with you guys
what [ __ ] is going on here I just like
to watch in peace man I like just
experience at all look at that
[ __ ] right there four-time world
champion by 4 ok or yeah you know and
everybody should see that guy cuz he
couldn't be thicker and and it's so
apparent he could knock me out so
quickly it's just so funny
mmm he doesn't seem 5'4 but he is but
he's looking off like that one too
always for next game he's Hawaiian no
Filipino but born in Hawaii yeah really
good guy man really [ __ ] good guy
really interested by him more for the
fights station maybe I will look at him
nod to hang out Jeff yeah Jeff is such a
great guy
hey Jeff Foley shout out to Jeff Foley
boy Freddie Roach is officially short
yeah pretty short Wow every one of those
guys give me some trouble on the ring I
think have you appreciate you be pretty
other link helps to do yeah pretty good
the rest of it guys don't walk in the
Filipino gyms going who wants to bang
who wants to know I walk in and go Manny
Pacquiao sup yeah see what happens you
guys want to go up up and Manny you suck
yeah now you see the
precautions yes he's taken and ones
crying how can they do this event during
corona if she's gone through the [ __ ]
Ling er just to get it done you guys
everybody's getting tested multiple
times because a fight they digger their
own individual training rooms the winner
of the fight goes into a secluded like
area to take interviews it's what is
this man I mean I just for the record I
disagree with it before entering then
when they get back before entering the
hotel room and athletes temperature will
be taken I feel like if they found some
what card they're just not gonna say
anything I don't give a flying [ __ ] if
every athlete on the card got Corona all
of them would be just fine they're not
gonna say anything
first I don't care not gonna cancel I
know clearly now that I canceled
anything and I don't care hey don't
don't what listen the guy putting the
event on is the only one who should be
worried if he gets Curran at dana white
because his underlying health condition
I'll make it down make a call right now
you ready for my call I don't know you
seem to enrage me be good
well I rewatched the Mike Lee 21st and
fight Kevin Lee
now a couple things after watching that
I walk slightly hold on I have to watch
that fight I'm a-goin Richardson I want
to make those heavyweights yep I believe
I believe number one when khabib does
fight Tony Ferguson whenever doesn't
matter he escaped he wins
khabib wins I put all my money I could
be but I'm gonna tell you it was what
else Tony got taken down a ton in that
fight and got hit a lot and does get hit
a lot
and his his advantage is he's very good
I'm obviously amazing has crazy win
doesn't get tired in the world best card
in the world but great jujitsu if he
tries to stand and bang with Justin gay
Chi and Justin's wrestling is better oh
no aah then Tony's oh that's right Tony
was a wrestler to know I'm Jim I think
if he he was the you know it doesn't
matter no one's gonna Dressel if anybody
wrestling yeah Tony Justin doesn't
wrestle but it's a very dangerous fight
for Tony I think it's a more dangerous
it's a more dangerous fight than could
be for Tony because just whoa what's
like it to me it's like you know Tony
was plan to go scuba dive in the deep
ocean yeah and he was ready and his mind
was set to the sku type in deep waters
and go deep with khabib yeah and we know
exactly what your deep what you didn't
get into when you go deep-sea scuba
diving yeah and then you'll change your
plans
you're snorkeling and it's in hurricane
water who's gonna be choppy but and what
if you can get past the current then
you're fine right but that Kurtz a
[ __ ] yeah it kills a lot of
people yes but you got to get by that
current yes Tony will meet you halfway
and they start he will get ahead Tony
Tony got hit in the micro jobsite idiots
pedis you got hit against Valerio yes
you know so there's a lot of yes a lot
of guys he does get hit now if you get
hit by just engaging you don't get up he
has me it's such a dangerous fight for
Tony if you like dogs get gay choose the
dog there's a ton of dogs on this fight
card you can make some money there's a
parlay you can make and we should do it
I think you put $100 you can win 15,000
and the chance of these underdogs and
winning are pretty [ __ ] good I'll do
it all right let's do it let's do it hot
rod bet for us okay good let's do it now
let me ask you this does
Keiichi does he gas i camera I haven't
seen him gasps he's tired he does get
tired night because now that the time
she cried she has about 18 minutes of
pure [ __ ] ground
yeah and it's tough to deal with it's
possible and Tony gets it yeah it to me
it's a more exciting and more dangerous
fight than Tony kabhi kabhi he's that
he's not gonna submit Tony he's not
gonna pound Tony out the only way that
fight is a finish if Tony submit them or
cuts them up and doctor stoppage and
Tony wins detail or Joe's decision Tony
what is just as ranking for that's right
was there anybody else you would have
liked to see no fight this is the
perfect fight Walt Conor McGregor
obviously Conor McGregor I think I think
Connors gonna fight Mazda at all
yep for you oh my god I can't take that
fight come on Ramon off does that wake
your trouser snake oh my god maybe more
than anything
oh you like that oh my god maybe more
than anything well because there's
always two of the best strikers in that
division like well here's that one your
brain or Dana cuz you so spike kymaro's
man for the title yeah I'm Dana goes no
we have something bigger so what would
be bigger than Camaros meant for the
title has to be Connor or you ready for
this old man or Nick Nick Diaz with with
with no s70 Nick with with Cosmo
defending his brother's honor I love its
storyline - I love it I love Nick Diaz
it's been so long I just think it's a
little maas well [ __ ] would beat them
but I'm just saying it's a when you talk
about bigger fights for his views or its
Connor Nick right surely things
something bigger than fighting for the
title I would just love to see MOSFET
out Connor I'd love to see them try to
slug that out that's how [ __ ] why
don't think of the build up [ __ ] [ __ ]
AFL titles Christ yeah yeah and look
when asked about Mozilla potentially
defend the bfb MFL title BMF title sorry
give me throw nail in there B M F title
against the Taurus on fight Island white
added very good point that's possibility
the author wants to fight on that fight
Island Massa wants fine fine
what's bigger than cilantro with find it
70 does he have trouble with 55 because
I'm a 50 yeah he get 250 received Moskva
all fight Tony first it also would be
you not getting that for a while though
but we're talking about something in the
next you know two months month or two
whoa you know no matter what happens
that gay Chi Tony fight they're not both
those guys get [ __ ] up so you're not
seeing you them for a while yeah so it
has I think Connor Moslems what's gonna
said June or late June and and when and
when miles at all was on my show on food
truck diaries his manager and him we're
like Connors the fight that's all we
wanted to Connors that's all they want I
bet I bet I wouldn't you deserves money
is that's where the big money is
goddamn I won't put some bets down all
right yeah that that partly would be fun
yeah it's crazy it's like 100 pays
15,000 and you look at the fight you
like [ __ ] those odds are pretty good now
for all of it to happen the parlay if
one guy loses in a weird decision
because MMA you get [ __ ] I don't like
parlay is parlays so if we if we bet
five fighters and they're all dogs all
five have to win no work for you get
your money if if four out of the five
win you don't get paid that's a better
underdog so know what to make this much
money you do but they're good bets
decent earth I like cash you're over
Hardy as a dog Dominick Cruz as the dogs
good gauging the dominant Cruz gives it
to any victim decision
what yep you don't say ok ok ok trousers
okay we give me another how do you say
why in um some example well it said
Korean Zombie I don't know greens very
easy as where where where where where
yeah I think time accrues beats of the
other system Jesus that's that's you
know else thinks that Kenneth Florian
what I haven't bring him did a breakdown
yesterday Oh somebody shred it out
that's mines great is he fighting it not
25 is 35 yes who's that guy go back
that's a mustache is that me on trt yeah
but he's much shorter than you Bubba
he's America's her suitors tithing yeah
there's a thick fellow so who is a
absolute ultimate winner absolutely good
medalists I mean he's just the shoe
division wait James is astonished and I
still think Cruz beat some decision
unless you're not Cruz out he's a vegan
hit though Mighty Mouse
he's B who's B J Dilla Chris did but
started say uno right yeah if you beat
him but you know I think I'm gonna
guilty oh dude BAM wait legend the only
reason I idol a of it but the only thing
it's not just layout when I saw what
Karthik Odegard Brown did to him boxing
wise I I think to myself
use the hyper set and he didn't expect
that out of in if you hear him talk
about that phasic I haven't using a
counter punch we weren't ready for the
ha oh you say you threw me off okay I
made some changes so we'll see all right
McDonough Chris you said his genius is
is the bad smartest smart mmm-ma strands
the Elon Musk yo fighting yeah he's the
Elon Musk Jesus
oh why cuz he sells footwork seminars on
his Instagram let's go get his footwork
if it does you should take them I will
well do you think I'm kidding you know
how this I tell you do it yeah I'll
[ __ ] buy that right now are you doing
it for free I'm no you can buy is it
free when is TJ back I don't know but he
seen me up [ __ ] when he comes
back it's gonna be him he's part of the
the thick boys bike club is he uh-huh
he's awesome
here's a white teenager I loved TJ and
what's not to love about that guy two
years and that was last year so yeah did
you have one more year April 2019 ya
know April 221 welcome back all right
not too far
well EPO never hurt anybody I'll show
you my hand thought it right now those
cameras you gotta give you got two years
a wolf or be sort of Doom's fighting
this weekend he got two years - he got
less time off - because of that you know
snitching cause what he told on I don't
know I'd loved he was come on food-truck
diary oh I wonder if it'd tell me a man
who's dead Chuck yeah for a little
leniency some time off at his age you
like do I tell on these guys you
probably aren't even
UFC or if you toll on the supplier like
a ball Co situation I get your money
dude ah I can't I do i I'm so proud of
UFC men I'm so proud of [ __ ] payin the
UFC me too
and the the event they're putting on
this weekend I want everybody to buy it
I love it buy it
don't [ __ ] pirate it like me I mean
like these other people don't make me
[ __ ] done your stream I'll be buying it
100% I'll be buying it
have you seen the promo no you guys want
to watch it section three minutes though
is this for the USA yeah for them coming
back
oh yeah chills eight different dudes I
like look at that whoa oh my the best i
like the governor it's awesome you say
I'm gonna kick your ass unbelievable
I have a boner Oh unbelievable Jesus
Christ an unbelievable wow what a great
promo little bail sucker both thumbs hey
Brendan I'm not watching may come back
with like in also seven-year layoff yeah
he's been a comic gonna fit cast boy by
God a lot of that [ __ ] about me behind
you like you're coming against Greg
Hardy Greg Hardy and I'm just massaging
your shoulders and I'm wearing a
loincloth and we don't know why he's bad
he's back and Bryan Collins in his
corner and he'd just see me doing this
against all odds yeah it's gonna be good
right now [ __ ] back kick use your
back hand back flip back to about do a
back flip
boy oh boy that's gonna be so exciting
we have to watch that together oh no I'm
saying just come nope no no because it's
my history Franco molester and a me Jeff
I love you I love franca I love the [ __ ]
doesn't Jeff like it nope see that see
the bunch of other people can't believe
a bunch of other people it's Corona
maybe some people but not a lot maybe
nope
give me some kind of engine sure he's
gonna chow you guys watching it hell
yeah I don't know how I'm gonna watch it
I bet you would be me you Jeff Hagen he
can Machado
no absolutely not maybe a couple other
people are you watching cat maybe
probably we're you know watch it kid
I was playing do a zoom watch all my
friends but then zooms like 40 minute
limit or something like that
also that's I know but still also hey
I'll help you it's also that's gay I
mean gay now does it I have sex with
guys but no no no like it's like but you
know what the slang gay we're just
FaceTime then Oh God Google hangout has
something where you guys can share
screams oh God look Johnny's gonna jack
off together be in the same room so no
so this is a quick one here are some
before and after photos of Edie from 90
day fiancé
you look like Patrick Swayze Patrick you
wait you're excited we talked about the
same Pat you talk about them all the
movie store pass through that last away
he is cute there though he's very small
but he passed Swayze now these buried 6
feet deep
yeah he just into his shoulders
yeah the Palin shows his kept growing up
yeah but he's kind of he's got are you
kind of see how is you weird body lead
his traps that he just doesn't happen
that yeah he says just no net he's a
barrel-chested
yeah I like him yeah a nice guy how do
you still watching any fiance know what
happens
I forget what happens to him but I
although the girl doesn't marry him
because she wants to have kids you don't
want kids and she left how many of them
are in love and does it work I don't
know the odds aren't good do they find
out about the woman's getting catfished
the black woman who's getting cat
I thought there so one is two hours long
six a long it's long I started watching
man the high castle on Amazon it's such
whoever wrote this is brilliant what it
was it's about be is if if the Nazis
would have won World War two it took
over America how do see excellent it
shows New York if the Nazis took over it
shows Times Square with this giant like
American flag that has a Nazi symbol in
them it's crazy yeah and then all and
then they call the Pacific the Japanese
Pacific is awfully the Japanese were a
Nazi side so they have the the Germans
gave them the west coast so San
Francisco is just all Japanese Hitler
initially wanted to create an axis of
power between the Japanese we considered
Asian Aryans the British she had
enormous respect for the British Empire
and their even their caste system
because remember the British happened
the British had what's called a great
chain of being yeah which was the God at
the table the King the aristocracy there
was there was a whole thing and so he he
was so puzzled he was always puzzled
that the British didn't want to form an
alliance finger hand and and then he
thought the United States was powerful
but that they were going to basically
crumble from the inside out because
their racial policies were all [ __ ]
humble yeah I know but he was Hitler so
great was crazy
he was a true sociopath you psycho yeah
as all these people how crazy is that
that's not one of the opening scenes
very good show yeah I was good so a male
man went to drop off a package at a
household and he found out that it was
the little girl a little girl's birthday
in the house so he left after dropping
off the package went to Dairy Queen to
buy her some ice cream like cupcakes
brought it back and gave it to her for
her birthday that's so [ __ ] great
guys sweet
okay so Elon Musk and his girlfriend
Grimes just had their son
Grimes yeah I think that's how you say
well they're the last name no she I
think is a singer so it's kinda like a
stage name but they had a baby boy a
couple days ago both the child and the
mom are fine but the weird thing is
people asked what the name is and this
is the name
according to Elon Musk he could be
trolling he probably is trolling this
bytecode and then the code is like Teddy
like I've been a few on decoded it's
like Anthony yeah some like Bailey musk
x AE a - 12 term and go by SpaceX and
you can't help but respect what the [ __ ]
he's done holy [ __ ] Lex Friedman who is
my buddy - Alexis I'm rolling about he
designed the self-driving stuff at MIT
for Tesla let's go yeah he's great black
belt in jujitsu and judo and a great
chess player and just a great guy that's
right just a great guy and and he he was
just talking about how musk is just one
of those guys who's just like if you say
I know we need more time to develop this
continue guys be quiet next year come on
let's grab a beer like did I know you
think it's gonna take a month he's just
the visionaries like okay I know next
year though you're gonna figure it out
Elon Musk didn't there's certain those
those those guys that whatever it takes
yes they're gonna somehow they're gonna
rise to the top correct okay so a
five-year-old boy in Utah was being
babysat by his older sister she fell
asleep while she was babysitting him
which he woke up she realized that the
keys to their family's car was gone the
car was gone and so was her
five-year-old little brother she freaked
out trying to find him meanwhile he
stole the car somehow managed to drive
it and made his way into the inner state
until a police officer pulled him over
the police officer saw this car
basically swerving back and forth and he
thought that the driver was
incapacitated or needed medical
assistance so he got pulled over and
then the police officer saw it was a
little boy that's him yeah he was trying
to go to California to buy a Lamborghini
and this is Utah Utah oh he's a big
five-year-old though I said he could be
in a thick boy schematic points buy
copies - ooh yeah well the whole
family's got a family
yeah the whole family is I don't know
how whether you do on the bikes and we
go for a distance but okay then have you
I'm where yeah it's just around the
block he's a big he's a big fire oh
that's big kid you'll buy a Lamborghini
would he sit does he have money he looks
for he had $3 with him so he kind of
came prepared like he had cash in his
wallet yeah that's just weird it looks
freaky yes really
he's a thick kid look at his shoulders
on that boy that's a five year old
that's a big five year I mean like human
14
I thought Tiger was thick that kid is
thick different yeah this is thick with
the K yeah take a hike
yeah Tigers got calves and yeah yeah
three dollars yeah yeah it was so cute
him talking to the police officer the
police officer is just like hey how'd
you get the car he's like oh I took the
keys wait can we say that yeah it's so
cute the main video yeah he made up for
in ambition
Adrian says he was going to drive to
California to buy a Lamborghini his
family says he's always loved cars but
they don't even know how he figured out
how to drive an actual smart kid that's
a little five-year-old 11 years younger
than me do an eye care home safe and
lesson learned
oh yeah a lot money to never leave the
keys out it will be a few that's a smart
little boy good it is and it is if he's
obsessed with cars like Tigers yeah I
get to my car no keys in the car see but
he's always messing my car and he like
if I left keys in he would take that
[ __ ] out scares you because little kids
car very industrious like a kid sure
yeah he's like that
yeah that's a smart little boy it's so
funny yeah three dollars that is such an
interesting thing my friend Allah who
spends his time he's super sup cars and
stuff he knows everything about cars
used to race even when I was little I
grew up with him when I was a little boy
I remember he would stop and look at
every motorcycle and owner he was
obsessed with cars I never of course
were I seen its genetic like my dad used
to die dude shut the [ __ ] up cuz I would
be in the back and I any cars that go by
could tell you model name all cars it's
amazing
actual passion I think it served my dad
or or just some people just have it I
don't know it's like wolf but if I
didn't have nice cars I was in cars
Tiger would it be in the cars
you think so yeah hundred percent I
don't know he said I think cars have a
thing there's nothing about it if you if
your dad is visually cars you'd be in
the car but there's something about the
engine sound the power the the artistry
of a chassis that just captures some
people's eyes some people are just it's
like so so some people have an eye for
fashion and they want to be designers
you know Isaac Mizrahi's his mother said
Isaac Mizrahi when he was four years old
noticed her high heels and said I don't
like those high heels I like the other
ones became alright um you remember that
monkey that was riding motorcycle on a
shitty catch that thing I just people
are sort of messaging me and it's it
seems pretty true that there's like a
weird culture where they this is like a
thing a tradition would have them a
monkey tied like with a chain to its
neck and then they let it go they learn
how to actually ride the motorcycle so
it's not actually powered they just
fling it and then they turn it around
and then they drag them back so it looks
like that monkey was trying to hold onto
the the kid to save his own life he's
being abused and the guy was pulling him
back really yeah it looked like it all
but you could see if you actually really
pay attention to it you'll see like that
guy's pushing it
hello you're right yeah he doesn't want
to go back you're right
oh oh I see what's happening
the monkey grabbed a little girl the
guys pulled yeah yeah the monkey I look
cuz it looks like the monkey's paw yeah
that's about to drag her into the
[ __ ] creeps lair so they're being
abused oh wow trying to run away yeah I
just holding onto her for dear life yeah
picked up picked up the wrong I know
I'll jump onto it do ya it's very sad
jump onto that sad jumping onto that
kids thick sister all right I'm like you
wanna win anywhere no no little tug war
that big bit what else you got ever so
mean where I kill the monkey kill the
guy it seems so weird yeah cuz it looked
like a legit kidnapping attempt from
what my did well I mean [ __ ] it's on a
motorcycle thing was weird uh here's a
awesome thing someone said this to me to
Adele look at her now what knob shot it
she got a uh she's single now she's a
horse yeah she was amazing that's
impressive as [ __ ] yeah she's not eating
at all oh well if she does the pipes
though yeah that's the question and also
is she healthy I mean she looks really
healthy under suede health can I see her
face I mean that's my you're right I
mean but sometimes people starve
themselves to a point where did she I
thought she was a big bone girl but you
know I mean that was just a lot of
weight just fat definitely a lot of
weight I was the same dude she's great
piece now dude good for her
I'm looking at I'm a [ __ ] liking dude
she's siedel you're single I mean what
the [ __ ] just a lot more money than you
do yeah but i'ma hold her piano players
kind of a fan of mine really yeah nice
and that's in May of last year
now juice thick there people lost you
know do but she's beautiful man she
still be what I mean - yo yo there that
is that's incredible yeah look it's
definitely a flex like about done young
lady good for her man huh yes he did I
need a close-up though I want she did
surgery
possible Hospital Brennan she's gonna
waste on it though I'm [ __ ] got a
booty thought words words Brian
obviously the weight went to our elbows
they're win-win when tomorrow I think
it's the dress I know what else you got
good for her good friend mr. here
remember we talked about this a little
while ago
strip club weather just delivering food
to people like at their door like sort
of an uber eats but for strippers so now
they're doing drive-thru strip club and
I'll show you
kidney girls get in the cars no they're
on this platforms and then I guess the
patrons pay 30 bucks just to drive in
and they'll get like a song or two that
they dance to and then they could pick
an item on the menu and then they just
deliver this way and then I'll show you
some of the girls all of this all right
get that going on can I go go back for
his neck let me see what's going on
paradise for this [ __ ] just one giggles
sure that her wedding day I'm a fan of
hers and they look real
oh look at her um does it look like she
does with her boobs whoa she's shaking
[ __ ] ah
well that's very that's not real man
that's creepy but it's a haunted house
we're strip club oh is that the Little
Dipper yeah that's a drive-in area and
there's one where they delivered food
here somewhere
well check this out - where's this at
Portland yeah well we're fans of
Portland I love Portland Oh go back up I
got I gotta see what same girl she's and
I'm a fan of hers to him are very I
guess she's a t-bone on her ass yeah I'm
a bit of a fan right there let's just
see what's going on there yeah yeah
house let me can I go back please up
those teams are Kovac right there if we
could just see no no over the other side
Jim there's long it right there let's
see what's going on there again I'm a
fan again what strange tattoos I know
her tosses she's got real tits
those are real those are real a lot of
tats a lot of white skin lot of real
tits yeah I appreciate it
old fashioned the women the
old-fashioned way little goth what I'm
what I'm about and I'm not afraid of a
little weight not afraid of a little of
of having a real body
yeah you know you get some love handles
some strippers out there I'm a big [ __ ]
with red hair who cares just a woman a
real woman well let's get chin good for
them for freaking it out yeah
being creative at a time and just too
many pictures here let's go to this one
this artist from Austria lush sucks he
did our easy to piece with you and uh
yeah I never he's alright he's been
doing a sort of trolling thing with 50
cent so he puts 50 cent on it's
controversial people's faces
so there's Mike Pence and then to cost
you six nine and then obviously if it
stands it's playing along with it two
fifties not gonna do anything
no no he's he's having fun with it and
that's Taylor Swift pretty interesting
alright I guess really good artists yeah
Donald wrong I'll take no I was here
done yet yeah because 50 was too mean I
was like [ __ ] keeps doing this man I got
me [ __ ] up he just keeps doing it yeah
he's hilarious amazing artists do
amazing he just puts on these giant
walls in Australia wow this is nice like
he's donating 30,000 shoes and 95,000
socks do you healthcare workers that's
cool they're actually designed that way
too
oh wow very cool that's really cool okay
let's go yeah alright check this out so
I want suddenly this what do you think
these Brendan they're supposed to be
loose Presto's this wasn't based off
yeah based off of a Korean soccer teams
outfits odd we're just like is it cool
what makes those oh you're wearing right
now these would be Nikes are they
special yeah they're max undefeated
not for you expensive you know I have to
get dude up at 7 a.m. and get a [ __ ]
weirdo I can wear them if I want you
could pray wear these they're not too
outlandish
yeah see-through laces look at this so
you said that baseball returned in South
Korea so this is the first pitch a
Bubble Boy a Bubble Boy yeah real Bubble
Boy no they just had him do some in
there yeah
yes pnz and the games and [ __ ] there's
ice dying for live content CAD you get
your nails done are you doing them
yourself I'm a scythe oh you gonna say
because of phase two you went to a nail
salon
oh no I'm Vietnamese cuz myself cuz J
tried getting a haircut cuz its stealth
denver's and face do know you can
Floyd's and wherever the [ __ ] get hair
cut but it's like a six-week waiting
list sake of so many people need
haircuts your boys getting here destined
no this whole [ __ ] pandemic what else
you got
that's it Barney trimming your hair is
yours just growing it off looks good
yeah [ __ ]
looks soft up top dude I washed it looks
like a soft soft dude nice right it's
course yeah it's a nice hair a good
length yeah I'm a good-looking guy I
want to thank the fans for coming out on
Moss and saying that thank you so much
everybody everyone loves the short hair
it really do I want to keep it for the
gold I mean for school like a melon I
don't know I'm gonna ask them it'd be so
much easy
where we cuz I wasn't gonna wear I got
to do all this stuff with my hair and
though I'll just keep it like this oh
yeah your gym coach yeah sure like in
here there but I gotta look shitty with
shaved without a beard yeah just look
bad what's up you look sick when you
feel I look gross I like a beard you
might look younger with the shaved head
and shaved beard so you might look like
mr. clean yeah I don't think you should
definitely have the facial hair short
hair well you can't for a Goldberg I
know that sucks
we'll see let me see what happens that
it that's it
those were good man very good well
Brennan he did it we were supposed to
have a guest
oh sweet Jim Jefferies yeah but we'll
get him but we want to save him for
in-person ones we do a Zumba Jim
Jefferies yeah Friday I have an idea
oh yeah this delious I'm still scared to
leave the house probably although don't
we open up Friday yeah we do should we
beat up Chris might be a great idea it's
a good idea not beat him up and take our
flat head instead of rub on my body get
to just rough him up for ethical enough
time to get read you know you say that
tiny guy read and then whack whack whack
his body
you know spank him give me how do you
been your house quarantine this whole
time what some get roughed up now you're
out and about roughed up welcome to the
one I'll give him a shove around welcome
to the wild
yep welcome to the wild give you a shove
around you about to meet our shovers
we're shoving back and forth or say hey
Chris you know what we got you for your
corn to celebrate quarantine being over
surf and turf surf you're the turd how
can we [ __ ] him up yeah I'd be like
really [ __ ] him up I think good I'd
really make him blunt get him on the
ground
I put my knee in his chest and make him
say Brian's the best yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right we'll see if he'll do it okay
all right kids well this has been real
it's been real it's been fun it's been
real fun uh maybe do some shooting and
Terran tactical Friday we'll see you
have no energy right now
we'll see okay got it that's it all
right
the spine kid route